ils ont tout fait pour que west des pet
les flots la dernière semaine elle n'est
pas venue aux répétitions elle la plante
est systématiquement donc de répéter
banon mais ça l'année
personne ne fait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
fait un jeune il va j'ai genre c'est
trop bien j'en mangeais de la chance
c'est vraiment beau à jeun georges pas
les lèvres pourquoi qui dépasse mais il
faut l'entretenir
du coup c'est trop bien genre la passe
comme si j'avais tous genres évidemment
que c'est dangereux de dire des choses
comme ça parce que d'abord de comparer
de dire qu'un voisin de 12 ans pour une
femme de 20 ans et c'est formidable moi
ça me met mal à l'aise parce que je me
dis que évidemment ça va peut-être
réveiller des instants pédophiles mais
si pardon excusez moi il n'y a rien de
normal quand pour un type de 20 ans et
plus de troupes d'avoir envie d'avoir
une femme de 12 ans pardon mais si
rajeunir son vagin et dire avoir un
vagin de 12 ans pour vous c'est un appel
au viol posez-vous des vraies questions
dans vos têtes c'est bouclé c'est le
finir c'est que c'est vous qui avez un
problème associé la pédophilie un vagin
de 12 ans se trouve que vraiment c'est
extrêmement grave alors la tête de ce
qu'ils font c'est pas mal bien au vu de
la polémique maeva elle s'est excusée
elle a réagi un jour plus tard regardez
je tiens à m'excuser parce que je me
suis très mal exprimé faut savoir que
voilà parfois quand je parle l'info
passe pas par le cerveau elle passe
directement par la mouche qui était très
choquée par ces propos parce que je
pense que ça détruit complètement le
rapport qu'alcon les jeunes filles avec
leur corps mais aussi les garçons parce
qu'il faut pas emmener cas les gars ici
qui sont aujourd'hui obsédé par cette
représentation du corps de la femme
parfaite et pardon excusez moi à 12 ans
hier
[Musique]
voilà c'est youtube sa chaîne c'est un
truc c'est un carton de fou son clip
mini mini j'ai vu des milliers de forums
aussi il a été vu 60000 ont vu
[Applaudissements]
chacun de ces sons cartonne pas besoin
de toi je pense qu'il parle de vous
ces sorties samedi déjà numéro 5 des
tendances il cumule plus de trois
millions quatre jours
[Musique]
oh oui
comme tout c'est le fly and win avait
cassé
toi
tu veux pas faire un duo avec une grande
star de la télé via l'agent voit pas il
finit
par deux fois ses mixes et qui sait ni
non monsieur jamais trop jeune
lui qui s'est mis oui vous êtes j'avais
fait pas
à la légère un jeune non personne est-ce
que tu connais en moi la personne au
bout la balade la jeune fille non désolé
je connais personne en fait c'est un
traitement encore j'aime beaucoup qui
lui
fait appel il obstacles pas parce que tu
appelles en vrai inès inès fait qu'ils
naissent pour un garçon c'est pas comme
ça revient très fort
jeudi renvoi ils m'appellent jacqueline
passent
des fois c'était galère au début en
chinois centré non mais c'est vrai ça
j'appelle habitués et après tu t'es
coupeau tout le monde appelait inox
parce que tu n'en ferais tout mon peuple
est nette mais moi je me suis dit knoxy
naissent sa passe était comme inox à
rentrer pas sur internet voit déjà des
gens qui l'avaient halimi tag ce que
j'ai mais des fois qu'ils étaient pas
exactement taxe
pas possible j'adore cette chanson
bilingue en espagnol
en fait c'est parce que j'étais au
mexique avec mes amis
c'est parce que j'étais au mexique avec
mes amis et j'ai rencontré une fille qui
est venue et elle a dit j'ai une méduse
qui m'a piqué non si dans d'autres
villes elle est venue gl et à la mer ils
me disent qu'ils doivent être
connaissais pas alors je connaissais pas
ouais et à mes potes ils ont dit on va
organiser en baisse avec elle mais moi
je voulais moi non sinon ça va être ma
maison et tout en plus il faut sucer
quand la méduse
[Applaudissements]
donc oui on me disait eynden et qu'ils
ont nouée sur la chaîne youtube ils
l'ont filmé alors et support des bons
délires un vrai bon délire sans passé
mais c'était pour rire c'est cool quoi
et alors non il ya eu un bayou bas elle
veut revenir en décembre ah ouais
mais nous a pas rien
j'ai essayé mais c'est vrai que sur les
grands boulevards
[Rires]
on a beaucoup parlé dans l'émission
originale et a eu quelques petites
différences et des religions et surtout
depuis son élimination de d'als le
blogueur aqua bay a diffusé un audio du
témoignage d'un membre de la production
de l'émission ça balance sec comme leur
est confié un membre de la production
aux blogueurs on était en répétition sur
le plateau et son danseur qui est
quelqu'un de très simple réservez et
gentil a pété un câble et lui a dit ce
que tout le monde pensait selon lui ce
annuel de techci aurait déclaré à welch
dnt une chieuse tu es une emmerdeuse tu
crois que tu es arrivé mais rappelle toi
que tu as 17 ans et ça peut s'arrêter du
jour au lendemain il va falloir que tu
commences à respecter les gens avec qui
tu travailles le danseur ourdi par la
production
mécanisée cette production a été honteux
avec west des petits [ __ ] 12h way
nourdine
ils ont ils ont tout fait pour que wes
den pète les plombs elle a réussi à pas
pété les plombs mais où est elle
heureusement pas elle a un entourage
formidable avons franchement
voilà et son entourage a dit arrêtez
bastia je suis désolé mais dans
d'ascendance or n'a pas parlé comme ça
une personnalité sinon mettre en valeur
le bourbier où là et si c'est le cas
c'est extrêmement grave parce que ça nul
à trévise et pendant la compétition
surtout gagner d'un simple et on la
regarde fièrement mais c'est pas parce
que tu peux ne pas être d'accord et
quelqu'un ne pas lire sur sa puissance
vers quoi lui dire est à 17 ans sont là
pour les mettre à l'heure où les hivers
mais rien à voir avec ça il a pas mal lu
par les exalte la dernière semaine elle
n'est pas venue aux répétitions elle la
plante est systématiquement donc du coup
de répéter banon mais ça l'année
non personne ne fait ça on est super
réglo mais le mal est fait qu'elle n'a
pas été respecté coiffeur maquilleur
contrairement à paris le regard de sa
douleur et groix ou maladroit mais je
veux dire ça va bon je dis oui mais tu
vas te ment ses ouailles justement il
faut lui apprendre peut-être certaines
bernès
et
les employeurs qui nous a rejoint vous
êtes vous êtes chanteur et sosie d'elvis
précis donc c'est vrai que c'est le
rock'n'roll moi c'est dick rivers et
johnny hallyday eddy mitchell
le reste c'est de la merde droite
est en train de nous insulter
[Musique]
lorsqu'il ya des gens il ya des gens qui
ont pris le rapport no âge et puis qui
se sont mis à divulguer de la haine sur
la société
[Applaudissements]
c'est un avertissement
compris moi ce que c'est qu'un vrai
chanteur
[Applaudissements]
jean
respect parce que le mec qui fait quand
même le stade de france qu'il a vendu
des millions de disques voilà merci peux
[Applaudissements]
tu le quittes un peu quoi mais c'est de
la merde
bien sûr qu'ils n'aiment pas booba je
peux te serrer la main merci j'aimerais
bien faire un featuring avec lui
c'est une nouvelle boom qui est venu
secouer le petit monde de la télé
réalité ce week-end un candidat accusé
d'agression sexuelle sur mineur par une
ancienne candidate alix des moineaux on
m'a montré une vidéo et c'est une vidéo
d'agression sexuelle x ce soit vous
venez nous voir pour 7 a fait un
incroyable
cette vidéo alors inconnu parce que
apparemment comme on l'a vu dans le
récapitulatif il ya une vidéo qui tourne
et d'un candidat donc de télé réalité
qui a fait de nombreuses télé réalité
qui aurait eu un comportement déplacé
très déplacé avec une une jeune fille
mineure cessa de 16 ans et ça alors ce
qu'ils avaient sur cette vidéo en fait
parce que c'est vous qui avez en fait
c'est vous qui avez vraiment mes
danseuses l inverse oui c'est une
lanceuse d'allergie même si donc assise
sur un bord de lit ou je sais pas trop
enfin sur un truc luciani et la personne
en question s'avance vers elle n'a pas
de pantalon un tee-shirt et un t-shirt
blanc j'espère que cette vidéo sera
retrouvé et c'est très drôle visiblement
on attrape la jeune fille par les
cheveux elle joue pas sinon on essaye de
demander des faveurs et elle refuse elle
pleure moi j'ai vu une personne en fait
la journée aux très ému a raconté je
pense que n'importe qui vous vous tous
vous voyez cette vidéo vous ne pouvez
pas rester la jeune fille pleure elle
hurle et a dû son aile dure une minute
trente elle pleure elle supplie elle dit
je t'en supplie arrête non moi je suis
désolé un men ans avec gerland qui
commence cette vidéo circule en fait
alors moi je vais vous expliquer dans
quel cadre on l'a montré parce qu'ils
trouvent que c'est une personne publique
également qui me l'a montré dans une
conférence de presse je goûte raquel
conférence de presse c'était la
conférence de presse après les
marseillais contre le résume la fao et
là on m'a sorcier la vidéo et pendant
que je regardais horrifié j'ai une
personne qui jacassent et dans mon
oreille me dire ah mais tu te rends
compte en plus la fille avait 16 ans
parce qu'elle n'a pas sa carte
d'identité plaqué sur le front et j'ai
pas inventé en détails sordides parce
que je pense que c'est assez sale comme
ça c'est un milieu de la chanson fait
tous des lâches clairement et les
productions protègent certaines choses
alors je sais pas pourquoi
moi quand j'ai expliqué à une personne
très haut placées d'une production ce
que je venais de voir quelques semaines
avant parce que je me suis retrouvé un
endroit où je savais que ça allait être
compliqué et je les fais en interne
parce que j'ai pas la vidéo je peux pas
aller porter plainte on m'a dit alors je
suis pas au courant de cette vidéo par
contre je sais qu'il ya eu des problèmes
avec d'autres personnes d'ailleurs on a
une personne qui ne souhaite pas venir à
cause d'eux ensuite on m'a dit
d'ailleurs les nounous ont été avertis
que ça peut être dangereux donc ils ont
une information qui fait qu' il faut
qu'ils soient un petit peu plus présent
et vigilant pour pas que cette personne
se retrouve seul avec des jeunes filles
qui sait de ce jeune homme a envie de se
dénoncer
et de dire qu'on parle de lui et le
fasse c'est moi j'ai mauvais coup là moi
je ne dénonce personnes jeunes et nominé
personne parce que la seule personne les
seules personnes à qui nos minerais les
personnes de cette situation ce sera
face aux institutions qui peuvent faire
quelque chose
merci il a peut-être avec nous ce soir
merci d'être avec nous en direct
voilà on voulait avoir votre version des
faits ce soir parce que l on veut à
chaque fois nous avoir les deux parties
va rappeler de quoi de quoi êtes vous
vous accuse alix et nabil
lors d'une soirée 10 voilà vous avez
fait une vidéo avec notamment une jeune
fille qui serait apparemment aux mineurs
et que vous l'auriez forcer à vous faire
une fellation elle alors écrit elle
aurait pleuré la vidéo de ce qu'ils nous
ont décrite est extrêmement choquant est
vraiment voilà on les voyait tous les
deux apparemment ils auraient vu cette
vidéo c'est un vidéo avec ce que vous
venez d'écrire ça n'existe pas je n'ai
jamais fait ça de ma vie filmée ou pas
filmer évidemment ça n'existe pas donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes sûr que ça ne
sortira pas parce que si ça existe si
elle existe des moments assez vite et
moi c'est moi qui ai dit aux blogueurs
parce qu'il ya des blogueurs qui ont dit
on à cette vidéo il m je leur ai dit
sortez cette vidéo je vous en supplie
avant j'aurais dit sortez la cette vidéo
je vous le demande moi parce qu'elle
n'existe pas l'objet il n'y a pas de
vidéo il n'y a pas de victime il n'y a
pas de procès il n'y a pas de plainte
j'avais un ancien ami qui s'appelle
sébastien dubois à l'époque nous dans
l'altérité on a souvent on est on peut
on peut se fâcher j'étais fâché que
cette personne et ils voulaient me nuire
c'est à dire que lui il allait raconter
ça à knicks en disant moi j'ai vu ça sur
ille à gg une vidéo sur ilan en train de
faire si longtemps de faire ça ok il n'a
jamais de montrer il n'a jamais montré
pardon de vidéos où je suis en train
d'agresser une fiche de 11 me dit qu'il
l'a encore montré il ya un mois
quelqu'un aux états unis et puis que
sans doute après vos interventions c'est
ce qu'on me dit mais je vous laisse
répondre et peut-être qu'il aurait été
contraint obligé menacé par vous de
supprimer cette vidéo voilà ce qu'on est
alors je vous pose la question je vous
dise hercules sur moi déjà je me lasse
persson alors justement ça là dessus
nabil hier mais m'a dit que oui mais il
contraire oui mais à un moment donné si
vous tout le monde commence à écouter
une habile qui aujourd'hui est bannie
des réseaux sonabhy nous a fait écouter
un habile et vous avez écouté quoi vous
a fait écouter un morceau d'air d'une
conversation qui a été enregistrée à mon
insu ils étaient divisés sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur un plateau de télé sous
ce qui est interdite qui a été montée
parce que dans la conversation il montre
sa médias commencent à se renvoyer
personne en habits mais jamais de la vie
si je sais où alors il dit qu'il y avait
un tueur devant chez lui à un tueur
ouais c'est balance cap faut aller
porter plainte ne faut pas aller sur des
pmp parce que le problème qu'il ya c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nabil c'est quelqu'un qui
avait un rêve d'enfant de venir ici il a
réalisé son rêve et je suis très content
pour lui mais aussi pour soi mais par
contre faut aller porter plainte parce
que quand il ya une agression sexuelle
sur mineur soit disant mineures parce
que côtoyer mais si on pense aux choses
qui sont réelles quand on voit une vidéo
même d'une jeune fille personne peut
déterminer sa les mineurs ou pas chasser
dans un premier temps donc ça c'est une
chose comme qu'il faut relever de deux
ça voudrait dire que la personne qui a
filmé cette agression sexuelle était là
en train de filmer en train de voler à
hâter en train d'agresser une fille
sexuellement pas du tout pas du tout moi
c'est possible comme tu disais cyril il
ya peut-être des vidéos où je rigole
avec des filles alors évidemment pas
sourire parce que en fait ce qui se
passe ces skins ce qu'on a raconté hier
c'est bon les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent c'est donc celle votre aussi
un pote qui aurait montré cette vidéo
alix et c'est lui qui aurait dit regarde
la fille est mineur on peut aussi y a
pas de voie là c'est pas c'est lui qui
aurait dit voilà un film dirais même
alix nous a dit je ne savais pas que
c'était mai à lallaing servirait à rien
elle le dit pas elle n'a pas sa carte
d'identité sur son front ces squales
interview ne le dit pas mais moi je vous
explique un truc aujourd'hui justement
sera et les blogueurs ont dit qu'ils
allaient sortir cette vidéo moi je les
invite à la sortir la vidéo je les
invite à la sortir comme ça moi au moins
je serai blanchi parce qu'elle n'existe
pas aujourd'hui alix a demandé
l'ouverture d'une enquête le l'enquêté
est ouverte que c'est moi qui allait
porter plainte pour diffamation pour
dénonciation calomnieuse pour cyber
harcèlement pour harcèlement et et
pour incitation à la haine est question
que je me pose c'est que moi
personnellement si je suis victime enfin
je suis témoin pardon d'un viol sur
mineur et que la personne qui est en
face de moi à filmer ça je vais à la
police j'attends pas quatre ans pour
aller chez melty sans dire de nom à la
sortie de mon livre
moi c'est ce que je ferai la dic c'est
ce qu'elles soient
battus qu'ils allaient porter plainte
c'est ce qu'elle veut elle s était faut
il y aller alors il faut y aller donc
c'est chez moi j'étais parfois moi j'ai
vraiment porté plainte pour diffamation
parce que alix pense que comme tu ne dis
pas de nom tu ne peux pas porter plainte
pour diffamation c'était totalement faux
il a juste pour résumer la vidéo pour
vous n'existe pas donc la vidéo n'existe
pas elle n'existe pas vous dire et cham
envoyé tu as un habit banon donc je vous
êtes tranquille avec ça je suis
tranquille mais je suis plus que
tranquille
content de revenir voir booba il a
accepté de revenir que vous veniez c'est
sympa mais d'accepter germain dieu
je vais pas tarder alors est-ce que vous
avez très vite il excella dans la fois
jeté un peu vexé et enfin j'ai pas
compris pourquoi on pourrai pas débattre
normalement j'ai déjà une peu de
questions à lui poser pourquoi discuter
avec vous mais pourquoi je voudrais mais
voilà vous dis voilà vous que vous
lisiez ce que qu elle ressortie vous
avez là parfois parce que chez vous avez
été un petit peu vexé mais le ressenti
c'est quelqu'un qui veut pas discuter
qui a peut-être peur de 10 ans mais vous
avez 2 c à l'écouter on n'a pas parlé de
moi vous avez des choses à dire dit
quand j'ai voulu parler m'a dit et je
parle pas et en ce que tu es raciste bon
j'ai c'est d'abord c'est pas vrai en
débat moi j'ai bien sûr des millions de
personnes souffleur mois donc à des
millions de personnes racistes mon
impression à l'aller rennes sera
heureuse de le dollar c'est ce qu'ils
dégagent de toi de tes tweet d'accord et
quand la merde mais quand tu écris ou
aimons maghreb où sont mes negro c'est
pas raciste non
c'est de la négrophobie c'est du racisme
que sont les [ __ ] vous diriez negron
vous derrière toi
voilà voilà donc là c'est bien parce que
je voulais vous parliez ce soir parce
qu'il avait été et vexée voilà donc
comment ces jeux sans wayne on voit la
blessure narcissique moi je n'attaque
jamais la personne mais vous vous n'êtes
qu'hypocrisie là vous défendez des idées
en coulisse vous est même loin de ces
idées là vous n'avez aucune sincérité
regardez vos costumes ridicules
pas du tout je vous expliquez vous
n'avez pas regardé les bons fait
semblant a fait semblant d'avoir des
costumes bas de gamme que vous portez
pour avoir l'air populaire
non mais ça c'est pas bien riche verdès
voulait en fait vous n'êtes que n vous
transpirez l'art et tous mes sens noble
art et vous avez les yeux révulsés
lacanau lèvres vous et que vous exhaler
vous exhaler une forme de haine je vous
arrête parce que je vous ai fait pour
faire ça écoutez moi je pense
qu'effectivement les idées c'est une
chose l'être humain en est une autre
houllier ougandaise est ce que vous
dites pardon à genlis yahoo est ce que
vous lui dites me com ou qui on aura la
réponse de jean-michel juste après mais
je lui dis jamais pardon je leur ai dit
nico mots que jean médias
[Applaudissements]
les fans du comics
avec nous ex candidate de télé-réalité
23 ans un million de followers sur
instinct a plu à deux reprises dans deux
émissions différentes donc l'avant
dernière et la dernière donc dans les
princes de l'amour quand j'ai eu mes
prétendants dont on m'a demandé
d'accélérer le pas avec un de mes
prétendants de l'embrasser et des choses
comme ça dans ma dana mission donc
objectif reste du monde la production à
plusieurs reprises m'a dit rapproche toi
d'ailleurs à l'époque c'était ilan gens
proches soient dylan on aimerait que tu
te rapproches dylan et c'est moi ilan
physiquement c'était pas mon style et
voilà je très gentil mais voilà sans
plus et en fait j'ai appris par la suite
quand j'ai été éliminé au premier tour
que c'était à cause de ça parce que je
ne voulais pas faire d'histoires avec
des garçons qui candidate de télé
réalité m'a dit la semaine dernière elle
m'a raconté qu'elle était sur une
émission je peux pas donner le nom elle
était sur une émission la productrice
lui avait dit si tu ne couche pas les
termes exacts un signe il ne couche pas
on te met à l'écart et honteux virtu ne
refera plus d'émissions avec vous donc
là ça s'apparente à des pressions qui
songe que tu as tu reçu des menaces et
des pressions par equis et c'est pas des
menaces mais c'est de la pression c'est
par exemple ce genre de choses où tu
dois faire des histoires tu dois faire
des soirées garçon tu dois t'en brouille
avec certaines personnes parce que sinon
tu n'es pas vu à la télé donc à qu'est
ce que tu fais en télé si tu ne cites on
ne te voit pas c'est cdc dépression
comme ça en fait c'est plutôt la télé y
a rien de méchant c'est si vous arrivez
vous êtes un petit peu calme où les pas
des amourettes voulais pas montrer autre
chose bah pardon mais dans ces cas là
pour nous vous dire mais faut pas forme
avoir la télévision a ouvert une
mystique alors moi personnellement
c'était pas mon cas je pense que +20
j'ai quand même du caractère j'ai jamais
eu de problème à faire des histoires
avec des garçons qui me plaisait bien au
contraire j'ai eu même des histoires par
la suite à cause de ces garçons là où on
a exposé ma vie intime en télé et je
trouve ça n'est pas normal qu'on ne
recherche pas assez le passif des
candidats avant de les faire rentrer en
télé moi mon prétendants il a été accusé
six mois plus tard avant après avoir été
en prétendant de violences conjugales
j'ai notifié trois fois à la production
je vais virer moi même six mois plus
tard il a été accusé de violence
conjugale donc déjà il ya un gros
problème sur les recherches en amont sur
les candidats deuxième chose le suivi
psychologique il y à 0 suivi
psychologique s'il ya des productions
qui ont aussi et ça je le précise dans
ma deuxième télé une production qui
faisait des bandes sons qui coupait des
mots qui prenait d'autres zee tv de moi
et qui me faisait des phrases que je
n'avais jamais dit de ma vie qui
détruisait mon image qui détruisait mon
image c'est pour moi c'est un système
qui est ultra mal simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]